a giant of a vehicle is getting new
license plates it's going to be taking
to the highway in the US state of Nevada
it's the only place where it's allowed
to move freely and this is the big rig
that's going to be wearing the plates a
Freightliner inspiration truck outfitted
with a highway pilot autonomous driving
system developed by Mercedes and against
the mountain styling of Daimler says
this truck complements the mercedes-benz
future truck 2025 which they presented
last year in Germany it's a milestone
for us Freightliner rigs the first time
ever that a heavy-duty self-driving
truck has been granted a license for
public road use this truck is one of two
autonomous trucks that have been
licensed for public roads and regular
traffic in Nevada it's still a prototype
eventually mercedes plans to put
driverless long-haul rigs into series
production the first test took place
last year on a cordoned off section of a
German Autobahn afterwards Mercedes
continued testing the highway pilot
clocking up 16,000 kilometers per
vehicle on a test circuit and
configuring it for use on US highways
the Friedlander inspiration truck is
based on the US Freightliner Cascadia
evolution model with the addition of the
highway pilot system
disenzo like montant Zeilinger says the
sensor includes
a stereo camera which monitors the
highways lane lines and keeps the truck
in the lane the radar sensors at the
front of the truck regulate the distance
to the vehicle ahead of it and there are
interfaces to the powertrain brakes and
steering which is used for lateral
guidance cameras offer the driver a view
around the entire vehicle when the
driver activates the highway pilot the
truck takes over the steering currently
that's allowed up to speeds of 60 miles
an hour the highway pilot lets the
driver know when they need to step in
for example when there's a construction
site or when the truck leaves the
highway in the meantime the driver can
do other things like take orders or
coordinate connections martin Zeilinger
says the driver is the core component of
the system they're not going to
eliminate the driver they're looking for
optimal ways to assist and support the
driver autonomous driving systems will
help the drivers stay fit and alert so
it's an important part of driver safety
and of economical operations it could
all be some farley the freed liners
interior is light and friendly in its
design during the hall the driver stays
in the driver's seat but the rig also
has an area for the driver to relax
during breaks
Martin says the company carried out
tests on their own test circuit they
determined that when truckers work on
something else autonomous driving helps
reduce driver fatigue by about 25
percent that's an added safety bonus for
everyone on the road the highway pilot
steers the rig and keeps it within the
lane lines it also has a collision
prevention function which maintains the
set speed or
adjusts it through braking but it
doesn't initiate lane changes or pass
other vehicles the technology will be
ready for series production in about ten
years
so which will be ready first
self-driving trucks or self-driving cars
gone been out of Daimler says we'll see
self-driving trucks on long stretches of
highway first before driverless cars in
the city highway traffic patterns on the
highway are much less complex and trucks
are on the road for long hours each day
so the technology is more urgent and
useful there that gives the trucking
industry an edge but the regulatory
framework isn't there yet road traffic
regulations need to be adapted and that
raises a lot of questions one issue is
what conditions manufacturers need to
meet to get a system licensed and street
legal but discussions are underway with
the regulatory authorities and he's
confident these issues will all be
addressed in the next few years mitten
hangeul re-emitted mitten helping in the
garden dust is a next theorem to
hospital